hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan today's episode is
brought to you by Telus talks business
have got a great face book page call
telus off business he could check out
and lots of resources and ideas for
canadian entrepreneurs today's question
comes from one of our pulse ox business
readers who is asking about do you need
a college or university education to be
able to two of the B's a successful
entrepreneur so the question came in
saying hi Evan this article's very
inspiring what always puzzles me though
about most of these success stories is
that most of them didn't finish their
college education is that they're
smarter than most people or is that they
were just really convinced that college
wouldn't help them with their with their
business someone please answer this for
me so thank you for the question that's
a really tough one I think the college
dropouts are more well-known it's a
bigger story I guess because they take
the road less traveled I think if you
look at most successful entrepreneurs
today most modern day successful
entrepreneurs you'll find that they did
go to college and university they could
be putting yourself at a disadvantage if
you didn't at least go and get your
undergraduate degree you get to meet new
people and just in case you have a
fallback plan you will get a job if the
business doesn't work out so if you
think if you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs now you'll find that most
of them did go to college or university
if you look at the previous successful
entrepreneurs you know the ones from the
past I think you'll find two things one
some of them may not have gone to
college university it wasn't for lack of
desire it was for usually a lack of
resources so they didn't have the money
to go or they were they might have
started and they needed to drop out
because they didn't have enough money so
they had to start something that just to
try to sustain themselves so that's
that's that's very common is that in
four previous entrepreneurs successful
entrepreneurs in history they may have
started but you know they didn't have
the ability to continue or even get
started because they didn't have the
money to do it it's not that they didn't
want to do it though and if you look at
a lot of those successful entrepreneurs
you'll also find that at the beginning
it really made them doubt themselves
because they didn't feel good enough
they felt inadequate they felt they
weren't as educators of the people and
they felt that that actually held them
back with the business so you'll find
the rare exception you'll find some
people who say you know college
university wasn't really helpful and I
didn't want to do that in want to launch
my own business instead but for the most
part you'll find that people either went
to college university or they wanted to
go but weren't able to so you won't find
many people will say don't go to college
university in my own experience I went
to university what university of toronto
and did my undergrad degree there and
that was a turning point for me so a lot
of my friends were going off to do jobs
i'd already started my business
part-time while i was in university and
i had the option to go and work at some
big companies and i thought you're on
i'm taking a year off and instead of
going to get a job I'm gonna go do my
own business and it was something I felt
I'm I might regret and a lot of times
you start a job and then you start
working on your career path and the
excitement about said in the business
starts to fade and then there's it's too
much of a risk to do because you have a
safe secure job wherever you do it right
at the beginning I felt a lot of those
opportunities would still be there for
me I could always go back and get those
jobs if after the one year didn't work
out so I did finish my university
education in terms of the undergrad
degree for the four years and then I
started off doing one year of doing my
own business full time and then never
went back to go get a job so it ended up
working out for me but I would always
recommend going to college university if
you can try to take courses that you
think will help you with your career and
also you know learn about
entrepreneurship if there's any kind of
entrepreneurship stream that you can
learn from try to get involved in the
different programs that they have if
there's anything that supports start up
and you kind of start up club or
investor club get involved in that and
also try to meet people who are
entrepreneurs I think one of the
greatest experience you can get and long
lasting from a college university
education is being able to meet
interesting people who can hopefully
become lifelong friends and also
potential business partners for you for
future ventures so hopefully I'll help I
know a lot of people think about that
decision should i go to college universe
or not that's my take on it at least in
terms of my experience and what famous
entrepreneurs have gone through so
thanks for the question for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up I'd also love to
hear all you have to think if you want
to leave a comment under the video or if
you have another question as well I
always read the common to come into and
I always appreciate those as well as the
the thumbs up the commensal thank you
and also don't forget to check out the
Telus talks business Facebook page they
were kind enough to sponsor this video
so thank you and a lot of great
resources there so thank you and we'll
see you in the next episode
you